human beings should not be treated as
Pawns in a political game what is
happening in terms of sending these
migrants most of whom have flee great
harm and sending them across the country
for the sake of some political
Showmanship it's just irresponsible
yeah that's vice president Kamala Harris
lashing out at Red State Governors for
bussing migrants into blue States even
dropping them outside her D.C residents
as critics slam her performance as the
borders are our next guest knows
firsthand how bad it's gotten at the
border
Pinal County Sheriff Arizona sheriff and
U.S Senate candidate Mark Lamb joins us
now Sheriff thank you for joining us my
pleasure thanks for having me on you
know Texas gets a lot of the attention
when it comes to the border for good
reason but Arizona is just as much in
the throes of the problems as any state
and so when you look at the vice
president saying well we shouldn't bust
them away from these border states for
one her Administration did the same
thing just maybe not to Blue cities and
for two is she not doing the same thing
she's using these people as political
pawns by keeping the Border open well
first of all what's irresponsible is not
closing the Border that's her job that's
the first irresponsible part the second
irresponsible part is the these
Governors from Arizona Texas yeah
they're busting people what are they
supposed to do with them but also for
every bus they send there's probably 10
to 20 buses that the U.S government
sends to different places a lot of red
States you don't hear them complaining
and they're also bringing them right
here to New York and other places like
Chicago so it's not just the the
governors it it's actually their
government as well you know I grew up in
Dalton Georgia it's a textile industry I
guarantee this rug was made there that's
how much carpets made there in the 80s
and 90s thousands of mostly Mexican
migrants came to Dalton Georgia most of
them illegally but their kids and now
grandkids are legal residents United
States what I hear from my friends I
went to school with they're of Mexican
descent over and over again as the
people coming now aren't coming for the
same reasons have you experienced that
well yeah and then the proof positive to
that is the fact that we've had 140
terrorists people that they've terraced
they've caught that have been on the
terrorist watch list you know there's 92
000 unaccompanied minors that have come
in thus far last week in the Yuma sector
uh or two weeks ago they had 1600 people
from 43 different countries we have
they've had 33 000 Chinese Nationals I
know I'm spitting out a lot of
Statistics but we need them that just
shows you it's not what it used to be we
got people this is a global thing yeah
we've got people coming here and a lot
of these folks do not have good
intentions and for those that do we have
a legal process for them to come into
this country they don't follow it well
and that's the other half this argument
if we weed it out if we had a vetting
process don't you feel like we would get
more people here for the right reasons
absolutely we've got to do a better job
the Congress and Senate have not done a
good job of putting a good immigration
plan together it's part of the reason
I'm running for the U.S Senate there we
go I've realized that there's only so
much I can do as a sheriff you know we
looked into my orcas there's a charge in
Arizona participating in or assisting a
human smuggling organization one of
those things says intentionally blah
blah blah blah or omissioned by a public
servant in His official public servant
duties yeah so my agency we put a case
together on them for human trafficking
and unfortunately because of the
supremacy Clauses of case law we weren't
able to take it all the way to the grand
jury which is why I said look the fight
has to say go to Washington DC so
anybody out there who wants to support
me then go to sheriff Lamborghini quick
you are running for Senate you've got a
big presence on social media maybe not a
national presence yes but I think you're
working on that you're running to unseat
Kirsten Cinema what makes you a better
Senator than Kirsten Cinema for Arizona
look the rising crime with the Border
crisis that this Administration
including Kamala Harris who's supposed
to be the Tsar has has created in this
country we now more than never need a
now more than ever need a proven
conservative crime fighter that knows
how to deal with the Border issue and
also knows how to deal with the rising
crime in this country that's why I'm
running I don't think there's going to
be any better candidate than me to deal
with the issues that we're dealing with
in this country Hey listen we appreciate
your life of service and good luck
likewise to you brother thank you for
having me on God yes sir I'm Steve Ducey
I'm Brian Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley
Earhart and click here to subscribe to
the Fox News YouTube page to catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis